some of America's most pristine forests
are under assault by illegal marijuana
cultivation that is ravaging the
environment federal narcotics agents
destroyed more than 1.4 million
marijuana plants last year according to
the US Forestry Service thousands of
pounds of trash and numerous toxic
chemicals were also taken out John
Blackstone joined agents in Southern
California as they try to crack down on
the illegal and dangerous growing
operation it's so rugged in the San
Bernardino National Forest that federal
agents searching for marijuana are
sometimes lifted from place to place by
helicopter we have a marijuana garden
down here with a known number of plants
and as of right now an unknown number of
suspects Dan Brio the u.s. Forest
Service is overseeing this undercover
operation armed officers from the Forest
Service and the California Department of
Fish and Wildlife go in first when they
determined the area is safe at least
relatively safe there's always chance
for poison oak rattlesnakes they let us
follow these are the kind of conditions
the enforcement team has to search
through to find these marijuana grows
what they found here is about 50 pounds
of marijuana cut and ready to be taken
out of the forest unfortunately we
didn't catch the cultivators but we did
catch their crop and it's a big crop
yeah at least 5,000 plants the plants
left behind are difficult to eradicate
the marijuana plants are growing beneath
the trees here hard to see from the air
in this rugged and remote territory but
about 5,000 of these plants are
scattered across about five acres of
this National Forest all of it fed by a
somewhat sophisticated irrigation system
this is a makeshift reservoir that the
criminals growing the marijuana have
actually created here in the National
Forest and they're diverting water from
a nearby stream into here the problem
almost isn't so much the marijuana as it
is the damage that they're doing to the
forest he had the environmental damages
she
in a way operations like this are less
of war on drugs and more a battle to
protect the environment the growers have
done more damage in the national forest
cutting down all this vegetation to
plant the marijuana but then down here
the enforcement team found what they
feared a bottle of car before and this
is a banned pesticide in the United
States that's turned this area basically
into a toxic waste dump even a small
amount of the pesticide can kill
wildlife and further denigrate this area
that includes a campsite filled with
trash it's the kind of damage done by
illegal marijuana cultivation on public
lands throughout the West on average 400
marijuana growing sites are found in
national forests each year for all the
ones that we find there's probably two
or three more that we didn't marijuana
now you can grow this legally in
California why does somebody come and do
this in a National Forest with all the
difficulty and the damage that they're
doing they're trying to avoid the rules
and regulations that the state has put
in place by coming out on federal land
and growing the marijuana illegally cut
down and bundle this clandestine
marijuana crop is carried out by air to
be destroyed
but the damage done to the forest
remains for CBS this morning John
Blackstone in the San Bernardino
National Forest it's an interesting
story about what they're doing yeah the
ingenious they are he made a good point
it's legal in California so why they
would go to national forests just a
circle but regulations that's very
irresponsible yeah